- We're gonna play little
game with one of these
little peppermints
- With a peppermint?
- A little fun Christmas game.
- Okay.
- Take the peppermint,
- Put it behind your back.
- Okay.
- Behind my back.
- Uh huh.
And put it in one of your hands,
but don't let me see which hand it is.
- Okay.
- Bring 'em out like this,
fists, so they both look the same.
- Okay.
You love Christmas right?
- I love Christmas.
- So listen,
(laughing in the audience)
don't give anything away.
If its in this hand,
I want you to think that
you're on the nice list.
And if its in this hand,
I want you to think
about the things you did
to be on the naughty list.
But try not to give anything away,
just think about it, okay?
- Okay.
I'm sweating.
- I'm--
(laughing in the audience)
it was a naughty year, huh?
Was it a naughty year?
(laughter)
I'm 100% I think its a--
- Don't answer that.
- I'm feeling naughty list.
I think that it in this hand.
Am I right?
Would ya show it to me?
- I can't stand you right now.
- Check it out.
See that?
Okay.
(laughter in the audience)
- How the hell'd you know that?
- That's a 50/50 shot.
Do it again,
put it behind you, put
it behind your back.
- Okay, okay, okay.
no, maybe.
- What's your favorite Christmas song?
- Uh, uh, uh, uh Noel.
- Noel?
- Ooh.
- What's a good Christmas carol?
Give me a couple ones.
♪ Jingle bells, jingle bell ♪
- Jungle bells.
- Jingle bells, easy one, easy one.
- Jingle bells and Noel, okay.
- [Lionel Richie] Jingle
bell, jingle bells.
- I'm gonna have you
sing a song in your head.
- Okay.
- Not out loud, just have
it be in your head, okay?
- So if its in this hand
I want you to sing Noel,
in your head.
- Okay.
And if its in this hand, I
want you to sing Jingle Bells,
in your head
Just in your head
- Okay.
Okay.
- Easy right?
- Um hm.
- I shouldn't be able to hear this.
Do you hear it?
Can-- Can you hear that?
- I can hear it.
I'm feeling-- what do you thing it is?
- Hm?
- What song do you think she's singin'?
- I have no idea.
(laughter)
Its Jingle Bells.
- It is Jingle Bells!
- I'm hearing Jingle Bells.
I think its in this hand, show me.
- You know what?
(laughter)
I was trying to fool you.
Like I didn't sing it.
- I have an ear for music.
I don't know, its a thing.
- You are freaking me out, be careful now.
- [Kelly] How do you do that?
- Here, one more time, one more time.
- I even didn't bounce,.
I didn't do anything like "Jingle bell",
I didn't do-- what, you do it!
I'm tired of being judged.
(laughter)
- [Lionel Richie] Okay, here.
- You, you do it.
- [Lionel Richie] All right, ready?
- Put it behind your back.
- [Lionel Richie] All right.
- What's a good Christmas movie?
- Oh, White Christmas.
Or Elf!
- Die Hard?
- Die Hard.
(laughing)
- That's controversial.
Die Hard, and what did you say?
- Alan Rickman best, like, villain.
Um, I said Elf or White Christmas.
- Elf-- Elf or White Christmas, okay?
- I like that, I like that.
- So bring out your fists
so they look the same.
- All right, ready?
- Yeah, bring 'em out.
- I'm gonna watch too.
(laughter)
- So, Lionel, if it's in your right hand,
I want you to imagine that
you are Will Ferrell, in Elf.
- Yes.
- Okay and if its in your left hand
I want you to imagine you are Bruce Willis
in the Christmas classic Die Hard.
- Yippee ki yay.
- Yeah.
- Yippyippi I kay, yeah.
- Okay, right hand, just say,
don't give anything away,
just say, "I'm an Elf".
- I'm an Elf.
(laughter)
- And if its in your left hand,
if you're Die Hard, just
say "Yippee ki yay".
- Yippee ki yay.
- 100% yippee ki yay.
You're Bruce Willis, it
should be right here.
Lets see.
Am I right?
- (whispering) Is it?
- Let's see.
- Yeah!
(applause)
Now...
- I'm not magical.
- That's not magic, listen--
That's not--
- Hey, hey, watch out, be careful.
(laughter)
- Where's my wallet?
(cross talk)